[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल वेलकम टू डे
15 ऑफ बेस्ट मास्टरी
कोर्स तो एक बार सबसे पहले आप मुझे बता
दीजिए सबको मेरी आवाज आ रही है नहीं आ
रही सबसे पहले आप एक बार मुझे यह बता
दीजिए सबको मेरी आवाज आ रही है या नहीं आ
रही
चैट में बस यस या नो बता देना
हूं ओके थैंक यू मिस्टर 003 सर असाइनमेंट
का सोल्यूशन बता दीजिएगा प्लीज हां एंड
में डेफिनेटली मैं आपको असाइनमेंट का आंसर
बता दूंगा उसका जो आंसर है तो सबसे पहले
हम अपना टॉपिक करेंगे मुझे बस 30 सेकंड का
टाइम दीजिए मुझे बस 30
सेकंड
चलो हम बात करते हैं आज जो टॉपिक पढ़ने
वाले हैं देखो लास्ट क्लास में मैंने जो
भी आपको पढ़ाया था वो रिलेटेड था आपका
बिल्कुल इसके लिए इफ कमांड यूज करने के
लिए या लॉजिक लगाने के लिए टेस्ट कमांड
टेस्ट स्टेटमेंट के बारे में बताया था
टेस्ट कमांड के बारे में कैसे आप कंडीशन
चेक कर सकते हैं उससे पहले मैंने आपको कुछ
अ क्या बताया था कुछ ये चेन ऑफ कमांड आप
मल्टीपल कमांड को कैसे ऐड कर सकते हैं एक
साथ चन चेनिंग कैसे कर सकते हैं वो सारे
करने के लिए करनी चीज बताया जा है तो आज
हम आज की क्लास हम पढ़ने वाले हैं काफी दो
इंपोर्टेंट कमांड्स और लॉजिस के बारे में
पढ़ने वाले हैं सबसे पहले तो इफ स्टेटमेंट
के बारे में पढ़ने वाले हैं दूसरा हम
पढ़ने वाले हैं एक केस स्टेटमेंट काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट है इफ स्टेटमेंट और के
स्टेटमेंट और इ इफ स्टेटमेंट कैसे यूज
करेंगे विद सिंटेक्स डिटेल में हम पढ़ने
वाले हैं एग्जांपल के साथ बीच में एक छोटा
सा असाइनमेंट टाइप का वो मैं आपको करके ही
दिखाऊंगा ताकि आपको समझ में आ जाए कैसे हम
स्टेटमेंट को यूज करते हैं और के
स्टेटमेंट को यूज करते हैं तो मुझे एक बार
मेरा लैपटॉप पीसी चार्ज लगाने
दीजिए यस न एवरीथिंग इ ओके नाउ गो बैक टू
अवर स्क्रीन जहां पर हम पढ़ने वाले हैं इ
क के बारे
में तो देखो चलते हैं हम अपने ये रहा देखो
इफ कंडीशंस के बारे में पढ़ने वाले हैं
आपको शायद स्क्रीन सबको क्लियर दिखाई दे
रही होगी यस ये रहा देखो जो इफ कंडीशन यूज
करते हैं ना वो बेसिकली आप देखो कोई भी
स्क्रिप्ट हुई या कुछ भी हो इफ को हम तभी
यूज करते हैं जब हमें कोई भी लॉजिक लॉजिक
लगाना होता है और किसी भी प्रोग्रामिंग
लैंग्वेज में या किसी भी स्क्रिप्टिंग में
आपको हर काम लॉजिक के साथ ही करना पड़ता
है विदाउट लॉजिक आपका कोई भी कांसेप्ट ही
नहीं है मतलब आप प्रोग्रामिंग लिखते ही
नहीं क्योंकि आप ऐसा तो नहीं कि बस सिंपल
वन लाइन के कोड लिखने होते हैं नहीं आपको
एक लॉजिक लगाना है उस लॉजिक पर अगर वो
ट्रू है तो वो उसका अकॉर्डिंग कोड
एग्जीक्यूट हो जाना चाहिए उसके अकॉर्डिंग
एक्शन परफॉर्म हो जाना चाहिए अगर वो लॉजिक
गलत है तो फिर गलत के अकॉर्डिंग उसका
एक्शन परफॉर्म हो जाना चाहिए सिंपली ये है
तो जो इफ कंडीशंस है ना उसको यूज करने के
लिए उसका जो सिंटेक्स होता है इस तरीके
होता है जो इफ का जो सिंटेक्स होता है
आपको स्क्रीन पर देखिए आप लिखते हैं सबसे
पहले इफ उसके बाद आप कंडीशन देते हैं
कंडीशन में किस तरीके से देते हैं कंडीशन
दो आपको मैं टेस्ट स्टेटमेंट पढ़ाया था ना
लास्ट क्लास में डे 14 में टेस्ट कमांड के
बारे में डबल ब्रैकेट का यूज करके हम
टेस्ट स्पेस देके उसके बाद हम पढ़ा था ये
वाला मैं अगर आपको बताऊ तो ये रहा दिस
वन ये रहा टेस्ट कमांड के बारे में बताया
था ना ये इनसाइड द स्क्वेयर ब्रैकेट यू
राइट यवर टेस्ट एटस एटस ठीक है तो ये ये
मैंने आपको पढ़ाया था तो यहां पर आप क्या
करोगे वही टेस्ट स्टेटमेंट का यूज करोगे
कंडीशन के अंदर देन उसके बाद आप यूज करोगे
सेमीकलन अब सेमीकलन का मतलब यहां पर क्या
है कि व्हेन सेल कम्स टू द सेमीकलन
हियर इट नोज दैट वी फिनिश्ड आवर कंडीशन
हियर इफ दैट कंडीशन इज ट्रू देन फॉलो दज
बिलो कंसेंट कमांड्स देखो सिंपली मतलब यह
है कि अगर कंडीशन के बाद मैंने सेमीकलन का
यूज किया मतलब क्या है कि यहां पर मेरी
कंडीशन खत्म होगी अब यहां पर क्या है कि
ये चेक किया जाए कि जो कंडीशन में यहां पर
मैंने अप्लाई किया है क्या ये ट्रू है या
फाल्स है अगर ये ट्रू है तो इसके बेसिस पर
फर्द जो कंसीक्वेंट कमांड्स ये वो कमांड्स
है जो एक आप एक्शन परफॉर्म करना चाहते हैं
यहां पर वो कमांड लिख होगे एक्शन परफॉर्म
करने वाली तो उन कमांड्स को यहां पर
एग्जीक्यूट किया जाएगा अगर जो ये इफ के
बाद में जो कंडीशंस है अगर वो फाल्स है
गलत है तो फिर क्या होगा इसके अंदर जो
फर्द जो कमांड्स है जो आपका एक्सस था वो
परफॉर्म नहीं होगा तो यह है इसका इफ का
क्या है सिंटेक्स तो हम चलते हैं अपने
टर्मिनल पर काली के टर्मिनल पर व पर हम
क्या है प्रैक्टिस करते
हैं प्रैक्टिस करते हैं चलो हम चलते हैं य
यस तो सबसे पहले हम क्या करते हैं
एक कंडीशन उसके लिए हम क्या बनाते है फाइल
बनाते है नो करते हैं नो मैं यूज करने
वाला नो को ए नैनो टेक्स्ट एडिटर का यूज
करने वाला हूं उसके बाद क्या है
मैं इफ उसके
बाद
कंडीशन स्क्रिप्ट डॉट एसए डॉ डॉट एस एच
करता हूं हिट एंटर किया और सबको आपको सबको
पता है सबसे पहले कौन सी लाइन हम यूज करते
हैं सी बैंग लाइन को हम यूज करते हैं अब
ये सबको पता होनी चाहिए ऐसा नहीं होना
चाहिए कि हम सि बैंग लाइन क्यों यूज करते
हैं क्योंकि हम डे 15 में है और डे से लेक
डे 15 तक हम सी बैक लाइन को यूज करते आ
रहे हैं तो सी बै लाइन का मतलब तो आपको
पता होना चाए सबसे पहले आप ओपन करते ही
आपके स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर सी बैंक लाइन को
यूज करना है तो अब बात करते हैं नेक्स्ट
हम कैसे यूज करते हैं इफ स्टेटमेंट को
देखो सबसे पहले मुझे यूज करना है इफ देन
मुझे टेस्ट स्टेटमेंट लगानी है देन ये ओपन
ब्रैकेट स्क्वेयर ब्रैकेट और क्ज स्क्वेयर
ब्रैकेट इसके बाद मुझे क्या करना है स्पेस
देना है इसके अंदर मैं काम ये रहा स्पेस
देना है देन मैं लिखा हूं मैं कंडीशन
लगाता हूं एक स्पेस टू ट उसके बाद ग्रेटर
देन ग्रेटर देन न मैं पर कंडीशन आप भी
बताइए क्या ये कंडीशन ट्रू है या फाल्स है
ग्रेटर दन व क्या दो एक से बड़ा है यस
ग्रेटर देन वन है तो उसके बाद क्या देन
देन गया देन उसके बा ट एंटर नेक्स्ट मैं
क्या करता हूं वैसे यही से मैं लिखना
स्टार्ट कर सकता हूं अपने कमांड को बट
क्या कि थोड़ा सा अच्छा दिखे तो मैं क्या
करता हूं एक टब दे देता हूं टब देके मैं
क्या लिखता हूं एक और देन मैं अपनी जो भी
कमांड करना चाहता हूं एकको टेस्ट
पास्ट टेस्ट पास्ट उसके बाद ये रहा एकको
टेस्ट पास्ट देन उसके बाद इसको क्लोज करने
का तरीका देखो आपने ये क्या कंपाउंड कमांड
है कंपाउंड कमांड क्या कते है रिजर्व वर्ड
से स्टार्ट होती है और रिजर्व वर्ड से
क्लोज होती है अब इसको स्टॉप करने के लिए
यूज कर देंगे प एफ आई इसका हम यूज करेंगे
फी का यूज करेंगे इसको स्टॉप करने के लिए
इफ से स्टार्ट हुआ फी से इसको क्लोज कर
दिया गया देन इसको मैं क्या करता हूं
कंट्रोल ए कंट्रोल एक्स ये हो गया सेव अब
मुझे इसको परमिशन देनी है सीच मोड देन
744 और देन इफ कंडीशन वाली ये रहा डट एच
देन अगर मैं एलस करता हूं हान एल करता हूं
और किसके लिए इफ कंडीशन वाले के लिए ये
देखो इसकी परमिशन क्या है रीड राइट
एग्जीक्यूट फर रीड रीड परमिशन है अब मैं
इसको क्या करता हूं एग्जीक्यूट करवाता हूं
इफ के साथ ये रहा डॉट एसस ट एंटर देखो
टेस्ट पास मतलब सक्सेसफुली हमारा कंडीशन
पास कर ही है अभी मैं क्या करता हूं अब
मैं इसको थोड़ा सा और मॉडिफाई करके दिखाता
हूं ये रहा मॉडिफाई करता हूं एंटर चलते
हैं अभी मैंने यहां पर ग्रेटर देन था अभी
मैं क्या कर रहा था यहां पर ग्रेटर देन था
अभी ग्रेटर देन था तो ये आपको पता चल गया
अभी मैं इसको क्या कर देता हूं टू की जगह
यहां पे थी लिख दिया यहां प लिख दिया
मैंने फाइव लिख दिया चलो मैंने यहां पर
फाइव लिख दिया कंट्रोल एक्स कंट्रोल s
कंट्रोल एक् देन उसके बाद फिर से
क्या करता हूं रन करता हूं हिट एंटर देखिए
अभी कुछ भी नहीं आया अभी कुछ भी नहीं आया
क्यों अभी देखिए एक बात बताइए अगर जब मेरी
कंडीशन फेल होगी तो मुझे अब पता ही नहीं
चल रहा कि मेरी जो जो कंडीशंस है जो
स्क्रिप्ट है ये पास है फेल है मुझे कुछ
नहीं पता चल रहा ब्लाइली सिंपली एजट करके
मैं स सक्सेस होगी तो अब इफ कंडीशन में भी
क्या होता है कि अगर एक कंडीशन ट्रू हुई
तो उसके बेस प एक्शन परफॉर्म कर दिया अगर
वो गलत हुई तो उसकी बेस प भी एक्शन
परफॉर्म करते हैं कंडीशन में वो कैसे
करेंगे अब इफ एल्स आप लोगों को पहले से ही
पता है तो न चलते हैं देन अभी यहां पर
लिखिए 2 ग्रेटर दन फ ठीक है 2 ग्रेटर दन फ
लिखा देन एक और टेस्ट पास ठीक है अगर यह
कंडीशन फाल्स होगी तो मैं क्या करूंगा
यहां पर मैं लिखूंगा एल्स इसके बाद क्या
लिखूंगा मैं एल्स अगर वो कंडीशन ू नहीं
हुई तो उसके बाद क्या कोड मेरा एग्जीक्यूट
होना चाहिए वो कोड मेरा एग्जीक्यूट होना
चाहिए को इसके बाद टेस्ट फेल्ड टेस्ट
फेल्ड टेस्ट मेरा क्या हो गया फेल हो गया
देन इसको मैं सेव करता हूं कंट्रोल ए
कंट्रोल एक्स देन मैं इसको एज करता हूं
फिर एंटर देखो अभी टेस्ट फेल्ड आ गया इससे
पहले जब हमने इस स्क्रिप्ट को रन किया था
इसको एजट किया था तो यहां पर क्या कुछ भी
शो नहीं कर रहा था क्योंकि वहां पर हमने
ये कंडीशन नहीं देखी भैया अगर आपकी जो
कंडीशंस है अगर वो फॉल्स हो गई अगर वो गलत
है तो मेरा क्या आउटपुट आना चाहिए तो क्या
आउटपुट आना चाहिए वो चीज मैंने इसमें
मेंशन की ही नहीं थी तो इस तरीके से अभी
मैंने आपको मेंशन करके दिखा दी अभी एक और
चीज दिखाता हूं इसमें इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है
ये रहा अगर हमें मल्टीपल कंडीशंस को यूज
करना हो चलो ये तो दो ही कंडीशन थी अगर
मुझे मल्टीपल कंडीशन को यूज करना है फॉर
एग्जांपल मैं इफ चाहता हूं कि ू ग्रेटर दन
व ओके मैंने लिखा ू यहां पर लिखा ग्रेटर
देन वन है ओके एक कंडीशन तो ये होगी 2
ग्रेटर दन
अगर मैं एक काम करता हूं य पर चलो य पर एक
वेरिएबल का नाम लेता हूं य पर लिखता हूं
नंबर नंबर देन मैं रीड करता हूं रीड कमांड
से रीड आईन प उसके बाद डबल
कोट एंटर
ए इंटी
जर आई इंटी जर वैल्यू टर इंटी जर वैल्यू
देन उसके बाद यह रहा
ये रहा उसके बाद नाम लिखता हूं उसका नंबर
एय ब नंबर ओके ये मैंने लिखा य पर उसके
बाद ये रहा इसके बाद मैं ड की जगह क्या
लिखता हूं
डॉलर
नंबर डॉलर नंबर लिखता हूं य पर मैं डबल
कोट के अंदर कर भी देता हूं ताकि इसकी जो
वैल्यू है अच्छे से चलो डबल कोट के अंदर
इसको मेंशन वैसे मेंशन करने की जरूरत थी
नहीं तो हम देखते हैं इंजर ये भी स्ट्रिंग
आ गया चलो देन अभी एक को अभी तो ये था एक
कंडीशन पास कर दी मैंने देन मैं क्या कर
रहा हूं चलो मल्टीपल कंडीशन को देना ना
मैंने तो चलो मल्टीपल कंडीशन को हम पास
करते हैं इधर उसके लिए अगर मल्टीपल कंडीशन
है आपकी तो आपको क्या मेंशन करना पड़ेगा
उसके लिए आप यूज करते हो एलिफ एलिफ ई एल
आई फी एलिफ देन नेक्स्ट कंडीशन नेक्स्ट
कंडीशन क्या है आपकी नेक्स्ट कंडीशन ये है
डॉलर अगर
आपका ये रहा डबल कोट इसके अर डबल कोटर
डॉलर नंबर अगर डॉलर नंबर मेरा अगर इक्वल
है
जस्ट डलर नंबर अगर मेरा इक्वल है ई क देन
आई विल पुट इट
वन गिव मी न वन मिनट दे सम न द
डोर
ब
हेलो एवरीवन सॉरी फॉर दैट देर सम
डिस्टरबेंस ऑन द गेट सॉरी फॉर दैट आई एम
रियली सॉरी तो अभी बात करते हैं हम एलिफ
डॉलर इक्वल अग मैं इसके बाद करहा क्या
इक्वल वन है अगर ये इक्वल वन है तो देन
कंडीशन अप्लाई करता हूं देन क्लोज करता
हूं उसके बाद देन हम क्या करते य
पर को इसके बाद क्या है अभी कंडीशन हम
लिखते हैं
कि इसमें क्या
[संगीत]
लिख नंबर
इज नंबर इ
इक्वल इक्वल टूव नंबर इ इक्वल टूव इसमें
हम क्या करते हैं इसमें लिखते हैं
हम नंबर इज ग्रेटर
देन ग्रेटर
देन देन वन ग्रेटर देन व ये दो कंडीशन सा
अगर ये दोनों कंडीशन मे नहीं हो रही फॉर
एग्जांपल की ये हा ग्रेटर देन उसको मैं
गरव नहीं करता इसको ग्रेटर देन करता हूं
100 गर 100 करता हूं या इक्वल टूवन है तो
दो कंडीशन ये तीन कंडीशन दो कंडीशन है
उसके बाद फेल होती है तो फदर हम क्या करते
है टेस्ट फेल टेस्ट फेल कर देते है
कंट्रोल एस करता
देन मैं कंट्रोल एक् अब इसको मैं एजट करता
हूं एजट करते हैं ट एंडर एंटर इंटी जर
वैल्यू मैंने लिखा टव ट एंटर किया तो नंबर
इज ग्रेटर दन वन नंबर इज ग्रेटर दन वन
सिंपली अगर फिर से मैं इसको एट करता हूं
अबके बार मैंने नंबर लिखा टू ये रहा टेस्ट
फेल हो गया फिर से अगर मैंने यहां पर
मेंशन किया देन एंटर इंटी जर वैल्यू मैंने
वन लिखा तो यहां पर क्या लिखा आपका नंबर इ
इक्वल टूव तो इस तरीके से आपने क्या किया
कि मल्टीपल कंडीशन को एक साथ आप यूज कर
सकते हो मल्टीपल कंडीशन की एक कंडीशन उसके
बाद फिर एलिफ दीजिए ऐसे सिंपली ये नहीं कि
आप एक ही बार एफ मल्टीपल एलिफ का आप यूज
कर सकते हो कि इफ र एलिफ कंडीशन देन एक्शन
उसके बाद एलिफ कंडीशन देन फ उसके बाद आपकी
कमांड एफ कंडीशन देन उसके बाद लास्ट में
आप क्या करना है एल्स कमांड का आप यूज कर
सकते हैं उसके बाद आप क्या कर सकते हो
एल्स कमांड का आप यूज कर सकते हो देन हम
बात करते हैं अब अगर हमें क्या करना पड़े
अगर मल्टीपल कमांड को चेन का यूज करना हो
इसमें अ क्या करना है अभी तो क मैं सिंपल
कमांड को यूज कर रहा हूं अब मुझे इसको चेन
सीक्वेंस में करना हो मतलब क्या है कि
सिंपली मैं इसको सीक्वेंस ऑफ चेंज जैसे कि
जो मैंने चेनिंग कमांड बताई थी जहां पर
डबल एपस एंड है और एंड इनका का यूज करना
सिखाया था अगर उनको उनके साथ करना हो तो
मैं कैसे कर सकता हूं चलो एक एग्जांपल और
लेते हैं हम कंबाइन करते हैं इनको तो मैं
क्या करना हूं आपको अी ये को स्किप करता
हूं ये रहा ननो के अंदर जाता हूं अब के बद
मैं इसको क्या करता हूं एक बार पूरे को
हटा देता हं इसको मैं क्या करता बार पूरे
को डिलीट कर देता हं नेक्स्ट एक नया कोड
हम लिखते है इ कंडीशन के बारे में यह रहा
अभी मैं क्या करता हूं मैंने क्या किया
ए मैं लिखा हूं वेरिएबल न इक्वल इसम मैं
करहा डॉलर उसके बाद ये कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन
करना उसके अंदर उसके बाद क्या कर कैट
फाइल फाइल डटी एक्स कर रहा एक्टी अभी कोई
ऐसी फाइल है नहीं देन मैं क्या कर रहा हूं
वेरिएबल टू देन उसके बाद डॉलर कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन कमांड के अंदर कैट उसके बाद
फाइल 02 t
एकटी देन उसके बाद मैं वेरिएबल थ्री लिया
उसके बाद डॉलर कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन कैट करता
हूं और उसके बाद फाइल 03 t एकटी 03 t एकटी
अभी वाव रट थ तीन वेरिएबल मैंने क्रिएट
किया अब मैं क्या चेक करना चाहता हूं अब
मैं क्या करता हूं कंडीशन अप्लाई करता हूं
सिंपली इफ अब मैंने क्या कंडीशन अप्लाई
किया ओपन ब्रैकेट देन मैं क्या करता हूं
डॉलर मेरा जो वार वन है डॉलर वार वन अगर
वो इक्वल है इक्वल डॉलर वार टू के डॉलर
वार टू के इक्वल एंड उसके बाद एक और
कंडीशन है एंड ऑपरेटर मेरा एक तो कंडीशन
ट्रू ही होनी चाहिए दूसरा देन ये रहा एक
कंडीशन य कर रहा हूं अगर डॉलर रा वार उसके
अंदर कंटेंट की बात कर रव उसके बाद जो
इक्वल है अगर
डॉलर
र के डॉलर बार थ के उसके इसको क्लोज कर
देता हूं अब क्या यय मेरी कंडीशन अगर य
दोनों ट्रू होंगी तो क्या करना है देन
आपको क्या करना है सिंपली नेक्स्ट लाइन पर
जाना है और रिमूव करना है
रिमूव
फाइल
टू
डॉट फाइल 02 फाइल 02 डटी एक्सटी आपको क्या
करना है रिमूव करना है अगर मेरा जो फाइल
वन है और फाइल टू इक्वल है फाइल वन और
फाइल थ्री इक्वल है मतलब नथ तो मैं क्या
करर रिमूव करना चाहता हूं फाइल फाइल टू को
एंड फाइल
03 डटी एक्सटी को डटी एक्सटी को इन तीनों
फाइल को मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं रिमूव
करना चाहता हूं ये कंडीशन मैंने बनाई अगर
ये कंडीशन फाल्स है तो एल्स क लगा रहा
एल्स इसके बाद क्या कर रहा हूं एक एल्स
एकको फाइल डज नॉट मैच
एकको
फाइल डज नॉट मैच ड नॉट मैच
ए ओके फाइल डज नॉट मैच उसके बाद कंडीशन
क्लोज कर देते हैं फी के साथ कंडीशन क्लोज
होती है उसके बाद य आपको सबको समझ में आ
रहा सबको देखने को मिल रहा है स्क्रीन पर
ऐसा तो नहीं किसी को स्क्रीन पर देखने को
नहीं मिल रहा ज्यादा फास्ट करवा रहा हूं
या मैं ज्यादा ही स्लो हो रहा हूं ये आप
देख सकते हो तो देन अब मैं क्या करता हूं
इसको कंट्रोल s करता हूं कंट्रोल एक्स कर
दिया अब इसको हम क्या करते हैं रन करते
हैं रन करने से पहले हमें क्या करना फाइल
तो क्रिएट करनी पड़ेगी ना फाइल तो हमें
पहले क्रिएट करनी पड़ेंगी अर पहले परमिशन
तो ऑलरेडी है इस पे हमारी अब इसको हम फाइल
क्रिएट करेंगे इनके अंदर कंटेंट डाल देता
हूं मैंने क्या किया एकको उसके बाद
अ इसमें डाल दिया सेम सेम
कंटेंट सेम कंटेंट देन इसको क्लोज उसके
बाद मैं क्या करता हूं इसके अंदर सब ये
रहा
फाइल अभी मेरे पास फाइल 0 0 डटी एक्सटी कर
देता हूं ट एंटर कर दिया देन 02 डटी एक्टी
देन उसके बाद मैं क्या कर रहा हं
0 तीनों में सेम कंटेंट मैंने इसमें ड कर
दिया उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं
स्क्रिप्ट को रन कर देता हूं इ कंडीशन डट
यप ट एंटर कर दिया मैंने अब क्या है फाइल
लाइन नंबर से टू मेनी आर्गुमेंट ओके फाइल
डजन मैच ओके आई विल चेक सम टाइपो एरर दे
सम टाइपो एरर टूथ 4 5 6 से टू मेनी
आर्गुमेंट
ओके लर वन हम इसको क्या कर देते हैं चलो
हम एक काम कर देते हैं ना
सिंपली वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग से रोक लेंगे हां
वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग हो गया ना वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग से हम इसको क्या करते हैं
स्टॉप कर देते हैं चलो अभी मैं इसको क्या
करता देखो डीबगिंग भी ऐसे ही होती है आपके
कोड में एरर आ रही तो सिंपली आपको सोचो कि
वहां पर क्या है
वो हो रहा है ब स्प्लिटिंग हो रही है तो
कंट्रोल एस एक्स चलो अभी करते हैं हम रन
ये रहा अभी रन कर दिया मैंने देन अभी मैं
क्या करता हूं आपको अगर एलस करता हूं एल
करके देखिए फाइल 0 एक्सटी ही बची है और
हालांकि मैंने क्या किया था फिर से देखा
फाइल एकको सेम कंटेंट फाइल वन है फाइल टू
क्रिएट फिर से किया मैंने फाइल थ्र दिखाता
हूं आपको फाइल थ कर देता हूं अभी फाइल 3
एक्सटी और एल करके दिखाता हूं आपको अभी
फाइल व फाइल टू फाइल थ तीनों दिखाई दे रही
है लेकिन तीनों में सेम कंटेंट है मैं
अपने स्क्रिप्ट को रन कर देता हूं रा
सिंपली स्क्रिप्ट को मैंने क्या कर दिया
रन कर दिया अभी देखिए अभी मैं एल कर दे
फाइल मतलब क्योंकि जो मेरी कंडीशन थी वो
ट्रू हुई और इसने क्या कर दिया एग्जिट
करवा दिया अब मैं क्या करता हूं फिर से
स्क्रिप्ट रन करता हूं यह रहा अभी क्या है
कैट फाइल टू फाइल नो सच फाइल डायरेक्टरी
फाइल डजन मैच क्योंकि उसम वो फाल्स होगी
और यहां पर क्या आ गया ये फाइल डज नॉट मैच
मतलब यहां पर मैच नहीं कर रही तो इस तरीके
से आप क्या कर रहे हो ये कंडीशन को वो कर
सकते हो यूज कर सकते हो आप एंड की जगह और
भी यूज कर सकते हो ऐसा नहीं कि इसी को य
एंड की जगह आप और भी यूज कर सकते हो
कंबाइन में ये था आपका स्क्रिप्ट को कैसे
रन करते हैं कंडीशन के साथ अगर मैं चाहू
तो इसको एंड की जगह और भी कर सकता हूं यह
रहा यह रहा ू इसके बाद थ क्रिएट करता हूं
एक
बार ट किया देन उसके बाद मैं क्या करता
हूं
ननो अभी इसकी जगर एंड की जग और यूज करता
हूं अगर एंड की जगह इसको और यूज करू आपको
क्या लगता है क्या आएगा आउटपुट य पर य रहा
डबल पाइप सिंबल नो नो नोनो डबल पाइप सिंबल
यह और है कंट्रोल एक्स एस और एक्स उसके
बाद इसको यूज कर रहा हूं यहा अय एट कर
दिया सक्सेसफुली एग्जीक्यूट हुआ है फिर भी
क्या है य ट्रू था क्योंकि इसमें से
कंडीशन वन ट्रू था तो सेकंड
ओबवियसली यूज ही नहीं क्योंकि अगर इसको
देखोगे आप ननो करके देखो ये कंडीशन ट्रू
है ये कंडीशन आपकी ट्रू है इसका मतलब क्या
है जो कंडीशन टू है ये जाएगा नहीं क्यों
पहली ट्रू होगी तो इसको तभी कंडीशन प
जाएगा सेकंड कंडीशन जाएगा नहीं फिर ट्रू
होगी तो इस रिमूव कर दिया अब इसके बाद ये
कंडीशन आपकी एग्जीक्यूट होगी य फाइल जो
आपकी कमांड थी एग्जीक्यूट होगी तो ये आपका
क्या था कौन सा है इफ कमांड है मैं आपको
नहीं एक प्रोजेक्ट लेता हूं छोटा सा
असाइनमेंट के साथ हम करते हैं इसको
असाइनमेंट क्या है ये रहा सिंपली हम चलते
हैं यह रहा आपका असाइनमेंट चलते है ये रहा
चलो इफ कंडीशन के साथ ही हम करने वाले हैं
यह रहा देखने मिल रहा य रहा सिनेरियो आपके
सामने क्या है कि यू आर वर्किंग ऑन ए
लिनक्स सर्वर एंड यू हैव यू आर हैविंग
प्रॉब्लम विद द सर्वर एंड योर बॉस गिवन ए
टास्क हे क्रिएट स्क्रिप्ट एंड इन दैट
पर्टिकुलर स्क्रिप्ट यू नीड टू लॉक द
मेमोरी यूसेज टू चेक फॉर फ्री परफॉर्मेंस
इशू यू नीड टू स्टोर दिस लॉक इन स्पेसिफिक
लोकेशन एंड यू आर गोइंग टू बी डिलीट दिस
लॉग पीकली देखो क्या है आप एक लिनक्स
सर्वर पर काम कर रहे हो लिनक्स एडमिन हो
और आपके साथ क्या एक प्रॉब्लम आई सर्वर के
साथ प्रॉब्लम है कि वहां पर क्या है कि
परफॉर्मेंस इशू हो रहा है परफॉर्मेंस इशू
का कारण क्या हो सकता है आपकी मेमोरी भी
हो सकती है तो आपके बॉस ने बोला हे
क्योंकि आप क्या नए नए कंपनी में नए नए
रिक्रूट हुए हैं और नए नए आपकी जॉब है तो
आप फ्रेश ही हो बोला हे एनी वन कोई भी नाम
हो सकता स कि आपको एक स्क्रिप्ट क्रिएट
करनी है स्क्रिप्ट में आपको क्या करना है
मेमोरी यूसेज को क्या करना है लॉक करना है
ताकि हम बाद में उसको परफॉर्मेंस ू चेक
करने के लिए यूज कर सके बस आपको सिंपली
यही काम करना है आपको ज्यादा हार्ड एंड
फास्ट काम नहीं करना है कि आपको पूरे बहुत
बड़े-बड़े कोड बनाने नहीं आपको एक मेमोरीज
को लॉक करना है किसी भी एक फाइल स्पेसिफिक
लोकेशन में अब फॉर एग्जांपल स्पेसिफिक
लोकेशन अपनी होम डायरेक्टरी में ले लेता
हूं उसके बाद क्या करते हैं क्या होता है
कि ये उसके बाद क्या ये फाइल पीरियोडिक
डिलीट भी हो रही होती है पीकली डिलीट भी
हो रही होती है लेन यह काम आपको नहीं करना
ये पकली डिलीट होर रती है लेकिन आपको
ध्यान में रखना है कि आपको एक फाइल क्रिएट
करनी है और उसमें क्या है कि आपको मेमोरी
यूसेज का लग लग जनरेट करने हैं मेमो यूसेज
के लोग उसके अंदर रखने हैं आपको और कहने
का मतलब अपेंड करके रखना है ताकि फदर
फ्यूचर्स में या उसके बेसिस पर हम क्या कर
सके नेटवर्क परफॉर्मेंस को मॉनिटर कर सके
सिंपली आपका य काम था अब आपका टास्क क्या
हुआ आपने सोचा मुझे क्या क्या करना पड़ेगा
सबसे पहले स्टेप वन मैंने क्या किया कि एक
स्क्रिप्ट क्रिएट करूंगा जिसका नाम मैंने
लिखा मेमोरी लगर ओके उसके बाद मुझे क्या
करना पड़ेगा भैया देखो मेरे पास तो
कंडीशंस लगानी ही पड़ेगी मेरे पास कोई
ऑप्शन नहीं है ना अब मैं कंडीशंस क्यों
लगाऊंगा ओबवियसली देखो पहले तो सिनेरियो
मुझे यह सोचना पड़ेगा कि हो सकता है कि
मैं सिस्टम में फाइल क्रिएट ही नहीं हुई
वो डायरेक्टरी है स्पेसिफिक लोकेशन में वो
डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट ही नहीं हुई है एक
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर जिसे मुझे वो करना है
वो क्रिएट नहीं हुई है तो मुझे वो भी
सोचना है वो सोचने के लिए मुझे यही चेक
करना पड़ेगा कि क्या ये मेरी जैसे मैंने
क्या किला दिस विल चेक इफ द फोल्डर डॉलर
होम मतलब आपके होम डायरेक्ट अंदर
परफॉर्मेंस नाम की एक डायरेक्टरी एजिस्ट
करती भी है या नहीं है क्योंकि ये चेक
करूंगा अगर एजिस्ट करती होगी फालतू में
मैं क्यों उसके ऊपर ओवरराइट करूं ना
क्योंकि उ ओवरराइट करोगे तो फालतू में
उसकी चीज डिलीट भी हो सकती है तो आप क्या
करोगे कि पहले मैं अपनी कंडीशन से ये चेक
करूंगा कि ये पर्टिकुलर जो डायरेक्टरी है
परफॉर्मेंस नाम की जिसके अंदर मैं अपनी
स्क्रिप्ट रखने वाला हूं क्या यह एजिस्ट
करती है नहीं करती तो मैं टेस्ट कंडीशन इफ
कंडीशन की हेल्प से चेक करूंगा अगर यह
एजिस्ट करती है तो सिंपली मैं मैसेज में
यह शो करूंगा कि ओ एक को मैं करूंगा कि
हां यह डायरेक्टरी एजिस्ट करती है देन अगर
ये डायरेक्टरी एजिस्ट नहीं करती है तो
सबसे पहले मैं क्या करूंगा परफॉर्मेंस नाम
की जो डायरेक्टरी है इसको मैं अपनी होम
डायरेक्टरी में क्रिएट करूंगा उसके बाद
स्टेप थ्री मेरा क्या है कि मुझे मेमोरी
यूसेज के लोग को परफॉर्मेंस डायरेक्टरी के
अंदर एक मेमोरी डॉट लॉग के नाम से एक फाइल
है उसमें क्या करना है अपेंड करवाना है
अपेंड करवाने के लिए आपको पता है कौन सा
सिंबल यूज करना है तो अभी जो मेमोरी यूसेज
के लिए सबसे बेस्ट कमांड कौन सी होती है
फ्री कमांड होती है सिंपली तो चलो मैं
इसके लिए कोड लिखता हूं तो मुझे क्या करना
है सबसे पहले मैं देखता हूं कि फ्री कमांड
से क्या क्या आता है देखो फ्री कमांड यूज
करता हूं देखो मेमोरी यूसेज की इंफॉर्मेशन
इसमें आ रही है तो अब मैं क्या करता हूं
सिंपली मेरे बोस्ट ने मेरे को टास्क दिया
तो मैं क्या कर ननो किया मैंने है ननो
उसके बाद क्या है मेमोरी मेमोरी उसके बाद
लगर लगर ड एएच कर दिया मैंने देन सिंपली
अब मैं क्या सबसे पहले सी बैंग लाइन ऐड
करूंगा ये सी बैंग
लाइन स्लैश बिन स्लश बैस देन एक मेरा काम
कंप्लीट अब मुझे सबसे पहले क्या करना है
कि मुझे उस कंडीशंस को फुलफिल करना है कि
मुझे चेक करना है कि क्या यह परफॉर्मेंस
नाम की
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री या नहीं करती मैं एक
कंडीशन यूज करता हूं मे पास टेस्ट
स्टेटमेंट यूज करता हूं और आपको पता है कि
अगर मुझे डायरेक्टरी चेक करनी हो अपनी
पर्टिकुलर लोकेशन पर तो उसके लिए
एक फ्लैग होता है एक ऑप्शन होता है जो आप
यूज कर सकते हो टेस्ट कमांड के साथ हान डी
पहले तोय चेक करेगा कि फाइल एजिस्ट करती
है या नहीं और फाइल में भी डायरेक्टरी
एजिस्ट करती है नहीं है तो उसके बाद कहां
पर चेक करनी है मुझे डॉलर होम डॉलर होम
डॉलर होम ये रहा डॉलर होम देन कौन सी
परफॉर्मेंस परफॉर्मेंस नाम की जो
डायरेक्टरी है वो क्या एजिस्ट करती भी है
या नहीं करती है देन उसके बाद यह कंडीशन
मुझे चेक करनी है अगर ये ट्रू है तो मुझे
क्या करना है सिंपली एकको कर देना है
की डॉलर
होम अभी आपको पता है कि हाउ बेस्ट प्रोसेस
कमांड लाइन डबल कोड कहां लगाना है सिंगल
कोड कहां लगाना है इ सब का आपको मुझे
बताने की जरूरत नहीं क्योंकि जितनी डिटेल
में मैंने बताया है कि शायद ही कोई बताता
होगा डॉलर होम उसके बाद डॉलर होम इसके बाद
परफॉर्मेंस पर फॉर्मेंस डलर होम
परफॉर्मेंस देन उसके बाद फोल्डर बोल सकता
हूं फोल्डर या डायरेक्टरी या बोल सकते हैं
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री अगर यह मेरी कंडीशंस
फॉल्स है इसका मतलब मुझे क्या करना है नई
डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट करनी होगी तो सिंपली एम
केडी आ आर करूंगा देन मैं किसके अंदर
करूंगा एम केडीआर डॉलर होम होम डायरेक्टरी
के अंदर परफॉर्मेंस नाम से ओके ये क्या कर
दिया मैंने डॉलर होम होम के अंदर
परफॉर्मेंस
पर परफॉर्मेंस परफॉर्मेंस नाम की
डायरेक्टरी मैं इसमें क्रिएट कर दिया
सिंपली उसके बाद फिर से मैं क्या कर रहा
हूं एक को करता हूं मुझे मैसेज देखो क्या
होता है ना कि एक को इसलिए यूज करते हैं
ताकि आपको पता रहेगा ट्रबल शूट करने में
डी बग करने में कि हां मैं जो कोड लिखा
जितना मैंने लिखा क्या वो पास हो रहा नहीं
हो रहा अदर वाइज आपको पता ही नहीं चले
मेरा कोड सक्सेसफुली एग्जिट हुआ नहीं हुआ
जब आप फाइनल जब पूरा कोड रन कर लेते हैं
तो जहां जहां पर आपको अपना आउटपुट देखना
होता है एक के देख के उसके बाद क्या उसको
हटा दीजिए फिर फाइनली आपको पता चल जाएगा
कि हां ये टेस्ट मेरा पास सक्सेसफुल है
ओके अब मैं यहां से एक हटा सकता हूं
नेक्स्ट ये नेक्स्ट ये ऐसे कर सकते हो अब
इसलिए मैं क्यों कर कर रहा हूं क्योंकि
मुझे पता रहे कि अभी मैं फदर में जब कमांड
को रन करूंगा स्क्रिप्ट को रन करूंगा तो
यहां पर हुआ क्या है वो पता चले तब मैं
क्या करर य पर फिर से देन डॉलर होम डॉलर
होम उसके बाद
परफॉर्मेंस परफॉर्मेंस उसके बाद देन
फोल्डर या
डायरेक्टरी डायरेक्टरी
क्रिएटेडटेड होगी देन अभी ये तो क्या था
मुझे सिंपली चेक करना था ये मुझे चेक करना
था
की डायरेक्टरी एजिस्ट करती है या नहीं
करती अगर एजिस्ट नहीं करती है तो मुझे
क्या करना है क्रिएट कर देना अब मेरे
एक्चुअल में टास्क क्या है मुझे अपेंड
करना है फ्री कमांड का आउटपुट किसके अंदर
मुझे क्या करना अपेंड करना है इसके अंदर
फ्री कमांड आ मुझे अपेंड करना है देन
किसके अंदर डॉलर
होम डॉलर होम उसके बाद परफॉर्मेंस
परफॉर्मेंस परफॉर्मेंस देन इसके अंदर मुझे
क्या करना है मेमोरी डॉट लॉग के अंदर इसको
मुझे क्या करना है अभी अपेंड करना है जब
जब मैं इसको रन करूंगा इसको मुझे क्या
करना है अपेंड करना है उसके बाद कंट्रोल
एस कंट्रोल एक्स उसके इसको परमिशन मेंशन
कर दी है सीच मोड देन उसको मुझे 744 अभी
अपने लिए रन कर रहा हूं और उसका क्या है
मेमोरी
लगर मेमोरी लगर लोटे इसकी परमिशन मैंने
मेंशन कर दी एलस करता हूं आपको ये देखने
को मिल रहा है अभी मैं क्या मेरे होम
डायरेक्ट अंदर कोई भी परफॉमेंस नाम की कोई
डायरेक्टरी आपको दिखाई दे रही है कोई भी
परफॉर्मेंस नाम की कोई भी डायरेक्टरी
दिखाई नहीं दे रही तब मैं क्या करता हूं
अपनी कमांड को रन करता हूं मेमोरी वाली
कमांड
को एओ मेमोरी ड एएच हिट एंटर कर दिया देखो
ये क्या हो डॉलर होम काली परफॉर्मेंस
डायरेक्टरी क्रिएटेड्रॉअर्नेविगेटर
डॉट लॉग करर देखो इसके अंदर
जाके ओके कार नहीं सॉरी सॉरी सॉर कैट था
ये सिंपली कैट ट एंटर अभी देखो इसके अंदर
ये क्या कर दिया एक एंट्री हो ग फिर से एक
बार कमांड को रन कर देता हूं रीस अभी क्या
है देखो होम काली परफॉर्मेंस फोल्डर या
डायरेक्टरी एजिस्ट एजिस्ट करता है और अगर
मैं इसको कैट करके दिखाता हूं तो दो
एंट्री होगी फिर से मैं रन करता हूं ये
रहा मल्टीपल टाइम फिर से एजिस्ट दिखा रहा
है और ये क्या रहा आपको देखने को मिल रगी
यह रहा कैट करना तीन एंट्री हो ग तो इस
तरीके से आपने सक्सेसफुली एक और स्क्रिप्ट
को बना लिया इफ कंडीशन के आधार पर अब चलते
हैं नेक्स्ट कंडीशन जो हमारी है जो हम
सीखने वाले हैं या जो स्टेटमेंट है य तो इ
स्टेटमेंट के बारे में मैंने पढ़ा है
नेक्स्ट स्टेटमेंट पढ़ाता हूं आपको केस
स्टेटमेंट के बारे में नेक्स्ट स्टेटमेंट
मेरी क्या है केस स्टेटमेंट तो अभी तक
मुझे बताइए कि आपको सब कुछ समझ में आया
नहीं आया स्टिल हैव एनी डाउट तो यू कैन
डायरेक्टली आस्क मी नाउ आई विल गिव यू वन
मिनट आप एक नेक्स्ट न मिनट में आप मुझसे
डाउट पूछ सकते हैं कि कोई भी डाउट है
रिलेटेड टू दिस कांसेप्ट इफ कंडीशन तो अभी
पूछ लीजिए किसी को कुछ रिपीट करवाना है या
कुछ समझ में नहीं आया कोई पर्टिकुलर चीज
या कुछ भी है मुझे अभी पूछ सकता है उसके
बाद हम फर्द नेक्स्ट टॉपिक पर चलते
हैं मुको क्या है आपको दिखाऊ दिखाऊंगा एक
बार समझा देता हूं उसका एक और बेस्ड ऑन
टास्क नहीं टास्क भीर तो अभी कर देंगे
हम बताइए
मुझे स्टिल एनी डाउट और
नॉट
चच कोड लास्ट रिपीटेड ओके य
रहा हां देखो इसमें क्या हुआ था
देखो य रहा मैंने सबसे पहले क्या किया इफ
कंडीशन का यूज करते हुए हान डी मतलब यह
चेक करना है कि होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर
परफॉर्मेंस नाम की जो फाइल है क्योंकि नक्
क्या करता है हर एक फाइल हर एक चीज को
फाइल समझता है तो फाइल में भी मुझे क्या
चेक करना है डायरेक्टरी परफॉर्मेंस नाम की
डायरेक्टरी एजिस्ट करती है या नहीं करती
सबसे पहले मुझे ये चेक करना है क्योंकि
मेरा टास्क यही है अगर एजिस्ट करती है तो
इसके बेसिस मुझे स्क्रीन पर दिखा दो कि
भैया आपकी जो होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर
परपोस नाम की
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री मेरा यह परफॉर्मेंस नाम
की डायरेक्टरी एजिस्ट नहीं करती है तो
मुझे क्या करना है ये क्रिएट करनी होगी तो
मैं क्या करूंगा अब अलग से जाके पहले
क्रिएट तो ना करूंगा मैं तो यहां पे दो
काम कर लिए ना मैंने पहले तो चेक कर लिया
कि हां मेरी डायरेक्टरी एजिस्ट करती है या
नहीं करती अगर मेरी डायरेक्टरी एजिस्ट
करती है तो ओके अगर एजिस्ट नहीं करती है
तो मैं क्या करूंगा इसमें ही कोड लिख
दूंगा एल्स के साथ कि मेरी डायरेक्टरी
एजिस्ट नहीं करती तो एमकेडी आई या इसके
अंदर परफॉर्मेंस नाम की डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट
कर दीजिए उसके बाद मुझे एकको करना है और
बता देना
क्रिएटेडटेड आर डायरेक्टली करता तो हर बार
जितनी बार भी आप क्या करते हैं इसको रन
करते उतनी बार ये परफॉर्मेंस नाम की
डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट करता मतलब अगर ऑलरेडी
क्रिएटेडटेड फिर से क्रिएट करने की कोशिश
करता हो सकता है आपको एरर देता या क्रिएट
करते राइट कर देता अभी इफ के इफ की इतनी
अच्छी ब्यूटी है कि इफ ने क्या कर दिया कि
आपकी चीजों को इजी कर दिया भैया एक काम
करो पहले चेक करो कि ये कंडीशन सेटिस्फाई
है अगर डायरेक्टरी है तो क्रिट करो और
डायरेक्टरी डायरेक्टरी है तो क्रिट मत करो
और डायरेक्टरी नहीं है तो क्रेट कर लो आप
मेरे को यूज कर सकते हो इस को उसके बाद
फ्री कमांड क्या करती है फ्री कमांड जब आप
यूज करते हो सिंपली तो फ्री कमांड आपका
क्या करता है मेमोरी यूसेज को शो करता है
मेमोरी यूसेज को शो करता है फ्री कमांड तो
इसने क्या कर फ्री कमांड जैसे रन करेगी
उसका जो भी आउटपुट आएगा उसको यहां पर
अपेंड कर दिया सिंगल यूज करता तो ये क्या
करता है उसके अंदर रिड जरूर करता है लेकिन
नेक्स्ट टाइम जब आप कमांड को रन करते तो
क्या करता उसी को रिरेट करता रहता उसके
अंदर अपेंडिंग नहीं करता मतलब उसके अंदर
ऐड नहीं करता अब ये क्या कर दिया इसने
परफॉर्म नाम के डायरेक्ट मेमोरी डलॉग के
अंदर इसको बार-बार ये क्या कर रहा है
अपेंड कर रहा है हर बार अब फ्री कमांड का
आउटपुट कैसा है देखो जो आपको अगर मैं फ्री
रन करता हूं क्या सिंपल नहीं है देखो यही
चीज तो है यह देखो मेमोरी स्वप ये रहा इधर
ही है सेम आउटपुट ये भी आ रहा है इसने
क्या करर इसके अंदर ये वो कर रहा है देखो
टोटल कितनी मेमोरी है यूज कितनी हो रही है
फ्री कितनी कितनी है शेयर्ड कितनी है बफर
कैच में कितनी और अवेलेबल कितनी है 29b
अवेलेबल है 39b मेरे पास टोटल है इसमें
10gb यूज हो चुकी है 26b फ्री है देन इतना
कैच में है स्वेप मेमोरी में कितनी यूज कर
रहा हूं 99000 मतलब 9gb यूज कर रहा हूं
यूज हो नहीं हो नहीं रही है मतलब टोटली
फ्री पड़ी है स्वेप मेमोरी तब यूज करते जब
ज्यादा हाई प्रोसेसिंग में यूज कर रहे हम
ज्यादा कुछ हार्ड एंड फास्ट तो कर नहीं
रहे ये है आपका मेमोरी कमांड की
इंफॉर्मेशन आपके सामने देखने को मिल रही
तो आई होप कि ये सबको अब समझ में आ रहा
होगा बताना
मिस्टर
ओके तो अभी 42 हो गया मुझे लगता है आपका
क्लास फरदर और लेना चाहिए क्या इट विल टेक
टाइम आपका टॉपिक जो है इट विल टेक टाइम
क्योंकि हो सकता आपको समझ में आए भी और
टाइम भी ले कल करवाना सही रहेगा या आज ही
करवा
बताओ आप लोग बताओ आज ही करवा नेक्स्ट केस
कमांड के बारे में स्टेटमेंट के बारे में
या कल बताऊ मतलब फ्रेश होक पढ़ोगे क्लास
में या आज ही करना चाहते हो बताइए
आप
आज ही करवा दीजिए
कल
देख नहीं पाएंगे आई डोंट नो कि व्ट आर यू
सेइंग मुझे समझ में नहीं आया क्या नहीं कर
पाओगे एक बार दोबारा बताना मुझे थोड़ा समझ
में नहीं
आया जल्दी बताओ
यार
नहीं नहीं कल का मतलब कि कल तो क्लास नहीं
होगी ना वन डे छोड़ के करता हूं ना मैं तो
बताओ एक दिन छोड़ के एक दिन ही कर दे
ना कल तो नहीं होगी तो परसों होगा मोस्ट
प्रोली
क्लास ओके चलो आज ही करवा देंगे नो इशू तो
हम बात करते हैं अभी के स्टेटमेंट के बारे
में अब बात करते हैं हम के स्टेटमेंट के
बारे में तो देखो केस स्टेटमेंट क्या होता
है केस स्टेटमेंट इट इज अनदर टाइप ऑफ
कमांड कंपाउंड कमांड यह भी एक दूसरे टाइप
ऑफ कंपाउंड कमांड है केस स्टेटमेंट क्या
है स्टार्ट एंड एंड यूजिंग द रिजर्व वर्ड
केस एंड इसक इसका अपोजिट सिंपली देखो बैस
में क्या है कि रिजर्व वर्ड के साथ लॉजिक
यूज करते हो कंडीशन यूज करो जिस वर्ड से
स्टार्ट होता है उसका अपोजिट से क्लोज
होता है सिंपली तो केस केस स्टेटमेंट का
क्या है केस से स्टार्ट होता है और केस का
अपोजिट करोगे ई एस ए सी के साथ ये क्या कर
रहा है क्लोज हो रहा है सिंपली ये इसका
क्या है सिंटेक्स है के स्टेटमेंट का यूज
करने का सिंटेक्स पूरा मैं आपको समझाऊ
उसके बाद देखो क्या है व्हेन वी नीड टू
क्रिएट मल्टीपल ब्रांचेस ऑफ लॉजिक इन टू अ
स्क्रिप्ट देन वी यूज मल्टीपल इफ एंड एलिफ
स्टेटमेंट देखो अभी आपने देखा अभी तो
मैंने कुछ ज्यादा दिखाया नहीं लेकिन अगर
आपको क्या हो सकता है कि मल्टीपल लॉजिस को
यूज करना है कि एक कंडीशन ये ट्रू हुई तो
ये करना है अगर ये ट्रू हुई तो यह करना है
ये ट्रू हुई तो यह करना है ऐसे आप 10 से
15 लॉजिस कुछ भी लॉजिस हो सकते हैं तो
वहां पर क्या कर मल्टीपल आप क्या करते हो
इफ एलिफ देन एलिफ देन एलिफ देन फिर एल्स
लास्ट में यूज करते हो 10 15 बार आप एलिफ
क का यूज करते हो तो इस केस में क्या है
कि आपकी जो के स्टेटमेंट है वो इंपोर्टेंट
रोल प्ले करती है जो के स्टेटमेंट क्या
करती है ये ओनली लॉजिकल चेक परफॉर्म करती
है सिंगल वेरिएबल के ऊपर अब इसमें ऐसा
नहीं है कुछ ऐसा लॉजिक की एफ की तरह बट
क्या है कि देखो ये क्या है एक सिंगल जो
वेरिएबल है उसी के बेसिस पर आपका लॉजिकल
चेक करेगी जो कंडीशंस है उसको चेक करेगी
ठीक है और दूसरा क्या है कि
ये एक कहते है ना कि कुछ कांटेक्ट में
अच्छा यूज करना के स्टेटमेंट को पूरा
रिप्लेसमेंट नहीं है कि हां इफ और एलिफ का
फुल रिप्लेसमेंट है कि हां के स्टेटमेंट
यूज कर सकते हैं नहीं हो सकता है ऐसी जगह
हो जहां पर के स्टेटमेंट
ना काम करे के स्टेटमेंट सक्सेस नहीं है
वहां पर इफ और एल तो हमेशा सक्सेस है
लेकिन हां कुछ हद तक कुछ
डॉलर नंबर अब डॉलर नंबर नॉट कंपलसरी मतलब
नंबर नॉट कंपलसरी नंबर कोई भी वेरिएबल का
नाम हो सकता है यह कंपलसरी नहीं कि नंबर
ही होना चाहिए य पर कोई भी वेरिएबल का नाम
हो सकता है यह सिंपली नंबर एक वेरिएबल का
नाम है लेकिन यहां पर सबसे इंपोर्टेंट
चीजें तो आपको हमेशा ध्यान में रखनी है
केस स्टेटमेंट के केस में यह चीज आपको
ध्यान में रखनी ही रखनी है अगर यह ध्यान
में रखोगे तो आपकी केस स्टेटमेंट काम नहीं
करेगी सबसे पहली बात आपको डॉलर सिंबल का
यूज करना अपलाई करना है क्यों क्योंकि
यहां पर वेरिएबल यूज हो रहा है और अगर
हमें वेरिएबल की वैल्यू को यहां पर यूज
करना है तो हमें डॉलर सिंबल का यूज करना
पड़ेगा और जो ये वैल्यू है हम अपने केसेस
के अगेंस्ट क्योंकि हम मल्टीपल केस देंगे
उसके अगेंस्ट इस वैल्यू को हम क्या कर रहे
हैं चेक कर रहे हैं और उसके आधार पर हम
क्या करते हैं उस कमांड को रन करते हैं कि
ये केस है ये केस इस वेरिएबल की वैल्यू के
साथ मैच किया तो ओके ये कंडीशन आपको रन कर
देनी है इस तरीके इसलिए ड सिंबल कंपलसरी
आपको देना ही इट प्लीज बर्न इट इन टू योर
माइंड आपको ये भूलना नहीं है के स्टेटमेंट
यूज करते वक्त सेकंड कंडीशन आपको
इंपोर्टेंट चीज जो ध्यान में रखनी है डबल
कोट यूज करना डबल कोट इसलिए यूज करो ताकि
वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग ना हो हो सकता है कि आपका
आउटपुट हो वो स्पेस सेपरेटेड हो तो वहां
पर वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग परफॉर्म होगी तो आपको
क्या है कि लॉट ऑफ एरर्स या हो सकता है कि
एरर ना आए तो डीबगिंग करने पड़ जाए जैसा
आप आउटपुट आ रहा हो वैसा ना आ र हो तो वो
सारी चीजें ध्यान में देखते हुए आपको क्या
करना है दो इंपोर्टेंट चीजों को ध्यान में
रखना है एक तो डॉलर सिंपल देना ही देना है
क्योंकि वेरिएबल है इस वैल्यू को हम केस
के साथ मैच करते हैं मल्टीपल केस के साथ
तभी हमारा आउटपुट आया है अगर डॉलर नहीं
दिया तो हमारा क्या होगा के स्टेटमेंट काम
ही नहीं करेगा हां जो डबल कोट के केस में
केस स्टेटमेंट काम करेगा बट वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग कर जाएगा वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग हुआ
तो आपको पता है व स्प्लिटिंग के कारण
प्रॉब्लम्स हो सकती है तो ये चीज मैंने
आपके स्क्रीन पर शो कर दिया ये रहा आपको
देखने को मिल रहा होगा ये पूरी चीज और
वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग अभी आपने देखा कंडीशन के
साथ में हम एक जगह पर जब यूज किया तो वड
स्प्लिटिंग होगी तो वहां पर जैसा हम
आउटपुट चाहि वैसा नहीं आया देन उसके बाद
आपको क्या करना है इन यूज करना है इन यहां
पर इन का मतलब क्या है इट टेल्स द सेल व्ट
फॉलोज आर द केसेस ट वी वांट टू
इन्वेस्टिगेट मतलब क्या है कि इसके बाद
मैं बता रहा हूं मे सेल को कि मुझे अब जो
ये वेरिएबल है इसकी वैल्यू के साथ कौन से
केस को इन्वेस्टिगेट करना है कौन से केसेस
को मुझे मैच करना है कौन स केसेस को मैं
क्या कर उसके साथ मैच करने वाला हूं तो वो
यह चीज है इन है जो फिक्स कीवर्ड है य पर
यह इसको बता रहा है सेल को सिंपली उसके
बाद एक और चीज ध्यान में रखना है आपको
यहां पर आपके केसेस होते हैं यहां पर आपके
क्या होंगे केस यहां पर आपके क्या होंगे
केस ही होंगे सिंपली आपके केस होंगे जो
आवर केस स्टेटमेंट विल बी ग्लोबिंग पैटन
जो हमारा केस स्टेट होगा वो एक ग्लोबिंग
पैटर्न ही होगा मोस्ट प्रोबेबली आपका
ग्लोबिंग पैटर्न होगा इफ द वेरिएबल मैचेस
द ग्लोबिंग पैटर्न देन इट इज कंसीडर्ड टू
हैव मैच दैट केस तभी इसको कंसीडर किया कि
ये केस मैच कर रहा है मोस्ट प्रोबेबली
यहां पर क्या आपका ग्लोबिंग पैटर्न होता
है बट क्या है कि मैं आपकी दो एग्जांपल
दिखाऊंगा ग्लोबिंग पैटर्न के साथ भी
दिखाऊंगा और वो भी नॉर्मल भी दिखाऊंगा बट
क्या कि ग्लोबिंग पैटर्न होता है य यहां
पर उसके बाद क्या है कि जब आपने यहां पर
केस दे दिया यहां पर मैं एग्जांपल लिया
इसलिए यहां पर
ये प्रॉपर ग्लोबिंग पैटर्न का यूज किया
देख ग्लोबिंग पैटर्न में क्या क्या आता है
स्टार आता है ये ब्रैकेट्स आता है ठीक है
स्के ब्रैकेट आता है देन एक और चीज आती है
मुझे अभी याद नहीं आ रहा तो यह चीज है ये
उसके बाद जब आप एक केस मेंशन कर देते हो
जिसके साथ आप मैच करना उसके बाद उसके बाद
आप मेंशन करते हो ये क्लोजिंग ब्रैकेट
कंपलसरी है भी क्लोजिंग ब्रैकेट यह बताता
है कि मेरा यह केस यहां पर फिनिश हो हो
गया जिसको मुझे यहां पर चेक करना है ये
फर्स्ट जो केस है ये मेरा यहां पर जीरो से
नाइन तक मुझे जो डॉलर नंबर में जो वैल्यू
आएगी ना वो जीरो से उसके साथ मैच करना अगर
रो से नाइन के बीच में कोई भी वैल्यू है
तो यहां पर इस कंडीशन को मैच करने यहां पर
वो कमांड लिख कमांड चूरन इधर इसके बाद
यहां पर आप कमांड लिखते हो जो स कमांड को
यहां पर क्या करना चाहते हैं आप मुझे ये
जूम हो गया ओके ये रहा जिस भी कमांड को आप
एजट करवाना चाहते इस पर्टिकुलर केस के साथ
उसके बाद अबब आपका काम खत्म हो गया देन
उसके बाद आपको करना है इस सेक आपको लास्ट
में यूज करना है ये आप इसका क्या है
कंडीशंस है ये आपका ये इसका सिंटेक्स है
एक चीज और इंपोर्टेंट पॉइंट आपको ध्यान
में रखना है कि अगर यह केस आपका मल्टीपल
केसेस के साथ मैच कर गई जो वैल्यू है यहां
पर जो अपने केस जिसके साथ आप चेक कर रहे
हो इस वैल्यू को किसके साथ अगर ये मल्टीपल
केस में सेम आ गई हो सकता है कि केस वन
केस 5 और केस से में यह वैल्यू मैच कर रही
है तो यह अब से लेकर डाउन के बीच में सबसे
पहले जो केस मैच करेगा उसी को उसी की
कमांड को ये एग्जीक्यूट करेगा या उसी को
ही एग्जीक्यूट करेगा यह चीज ध्यान में
रखना है आपको मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट कि सबसे
पहले जो आया उसी की वैल्यू को मैच करेगा
और उसके उसके जो कमांड्स है या उसका जो
एक्शन है उसके बेस प ये परफॉर्म करेगा चलो
हम एग्जांपल्स लेते हैं ये रहा एग्जांपल्स
लेते हैं तो हम इसका एग्जांपल्स क्या है
ये रहा मेरे पास मैं आपको शो करता हूं
एग्जांपल
देन य
र नो
एक न करते केस डॉट एस के नाम से और य पर
करता सबसे पहले बंग लाइन ड करते
हैं लान बिन और बेस बिन और बेस र अब मैं य
पर क्या करता हूं
सिंपली सबसे पहले मैं क्या करता हू रीड
कमांड का यू करता हूं रीड आ प प्रम करता
हूं देन एंड ये रहा ये क्या करना है
प्लीज एंटर ए नंबर एंटर ए नंबर यहां पर
आपको एक नंबर एंटर करना है देन ओके स्पेस
उसके बाद क्या करना है आपको नंबर नंबर नाम
का एक वेरिएबल क्रिएट कर लेना है जिके
अंदर इसकी वैल्यू आएगी उसके बाद मैं क्या
कर रहा हूं केस केस स्टेटमेंट का यूज करने
वाला हूं केस के बाद मुझे क्या करना है
डबल कोड देना है वड स्प्लिटिंग से बताने
के लिए और सबसे प्रायोरिटी क्या है मेरे
पास डॉलर सिंबल का मुझे यूज करना ही करना
है तो मैंने यहां पर क्या किया नंबर अब
इसके साथ मैं क्या मैचिंग करूंगा इन देन
उसके बाद यहां पर मैं क्या करने वाला हूं
ये यहां पर मैं वैसे स्टार्टिंग से लिखो
तब भी कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं लेकिन अच्छा लगे
इसलिए लिखता हूं यहां पर मैं क्या किया
जीरो से लेकर नान तक आपको मैच करना है
क्लोज किया इसके बाद मैं क्लोजिंग ब्रैकेट
अब यहां पर मैं कमांड लिखू मैं य पर
एग्जीक्यूट करवाना चाहता हूं मैं क्या कर
रहा हूं एकको कर रहा हूं उसके बाद आपको
क्या
करना यू
हैव यू हैव
एंटर्ड
एंटर्ड वन डिजिट नं एंटर्ड ए सिंगल डिजिट
वैल्यू एंटर्ड है सिंगल डिजिट वैल्यू उसके
बाद आपको सिंपली क्या करना है डबल सेमीकलन
के साथ इसको क्लोज करना है डबल सेमी कॉलन
के साथ इसको क्लोज करना है देन उसके बाद
क्या करना है इसको क्या कर रहा हूं जीरो
से लेकर जीरो से लेकर नाइन अब मैं डबल
डिजिट के लिए चेक कर रहा हूं जीरो से लेकर
नाइन ये रहा अब उसके बाद ये क्लोज देन मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं एकको उसके
बाद यू
हैव
एंटर्ड
एंटर्ड डबल
डिजिट डबल डिजिट वैल्यू डबल डिजिट वैल्यू
उसके बाद फिर से मुझे इसके डबल के साथ
मेंशन कर देता है उसके बाद मैं क्या करता
हूं सिंपली जीरो से लेकर नाइन फिर फिर से
जीरो से लेकर ना फिर से जीरो से लेकर ना
देन उसके बाद ी डिजिट वैल्यू उसके बाद
एकको
देन यू हैव
एंटर्ड
ट्रिपल
ट्रिपल डिजिट
वैल्यू ट्रिपल डिजिट वैल्यू उसके बाद ये
रहा देन उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं मेरा
काम खत्म मैं इना लिखना चाहता हूं सिंपली
मैंने क्या इसको क्लोज करना सेक अपोजिट ई
एस ए सी सिंपली अब मैं इसको क्या करता हूं
कंट्रोल ए कंट्रोल एक्स देन इसको मैं क्या
कर परमिशन मेंशन कर रहा हूं इसकी परमिशन
क्या है 744 उसके बाद क्या रहेगा मेरा केस
केस के नाम से य रहा अब मैं इसको क्या
करता एट करवाता हूं
केस केस ए हिट एंटर प्लीज एंटर नंबर मैंने
मेंशन किया 44 हिट एटर
यू हैव एंटर डबल डिजिट वैल्यू ओके अब मैं
क्या करता हूं फिर से अभी वैल्यू मैंने
एशन की न टू हिट एंटर यू हैव एंटर ए सिंगल
डिजिट वैल्यू उसके बाद फिर से मैं एट
करवाता हूं इसको अब क्या मैंने िप
फ यू हैव एंटर ट्रिपल डिजिट वैल्यू अब
क्या होगा अगर मैं फर डिजिट वैल्यू मेंशन
करता हूं फॉर एग्जांपल 67 89 कर दिया ट
एंटर प्लीज एंटर उसके बाद इसको कुछ भी
नहीं आया तो इसके लिए तो कोई कंडीशन लिखा
ही नहीं मैंने इसके लिए तो मैंने कोई
कंडीशन लिखा ही नहीं तो ये कैसे कर सक
देखो केस स्टेटमेंट क्या होता है कि आप एक
ऑप्शंस यूज कर सकते हो डिफॉल्ट केस
डिफॉल्ट केस मतलब क्या है कि आपने जितने
भी केसेस उसके ऊपर चेक किए अगर उनमें से
कोई भी नहीं है कोई भी नहीं है लाइक एल्स
कोई भी नहीं है तो आपको डिफॉल्ट केस आपका
एग्जीक्यूट करेगा ही करेगा और एक चीज
ध्यान रखना हमेशा आपको डिफॉल्ट केस को एंड
में यूज यूज करना है स्टार्टिंग में नहीं
हमेशा एंड में डिफॉल्ट केस कैसे मेंशन
करते हैं ये
रहा मेमोरी लोगो नहीं ये ननो केसेस ये रहा
डिफॉल्ट केस लिखने का तरीका ये होता है ये
रहा आप सिंपली यहां करना हूं अभी मैं ट
हिट एंटर और ये रहा डिफॉल्ट केस लिखने के
लिए सिंपली आपको यूज करना है स्टार और
क्लोज ब्रैकेट इस इसका मतलब है डिफॉल्ट
केस एक को मैं क्या करता हूं यहां पर एक
को उसके
बाद
यू हैव
एंटर्ड यू हैव एंटर्ड
ए यू
एंटर्ड
एंटर्ड य एंटर्ड ए नंबर ओके यू एंटर्ड ए
नंबर
नंबर नंबर ट
इज मोर देन थ मोरन ्र
डिजिट मोरन थ डिजिट उसके बाद इसको य अभी
देखो मैंने ऐसा किया और कंट्रोल एस करता
हूं ये क्या डिफॉल्ट वैल्यू के लिए हम य
यूज करते य रहा डिफॉल्ट वैल्यू के लिए यूज
कर उसके बाद य डिफल्टर इनम से कोई भी केस
आपका मैच नहीं किया तो यह एट करेगा ही
करेगा कंट्रोल एक्स उसके बाद इसको क्या
करता हूं य रहा
य डॉट केस ड एच देन मुझे क्या कर 7890 कर
दिया मैंने हिट एटर देखो ओके सॉरी अभी 789
जीरो हिट एंटर देखो यू हैव एंटर्ड ए नंबर
दैट इज मोर देन थ्री डिजिट वहा गलत लिखा
अभी मैं क्या कर रहा हूं फिर से ये गलत लि
इधर य रहा अभी मैंने फिर से लिखा कोई भी
वैल्यू लिख दी इतनी बड़ी इट एंटर य एंटर्ड
ए नंबर दैट इज मोर देन थ्री डिजिट अब ये आ
गया डिफॉल्ट केस मेंस कर दिया अब क्या
होगा अगर आप लोगों थोड़ा सा दिमाग में
डाउट आता कि सर अगर मैं इसको यहां पर इसको
यहां से अगर मैं कट करके अगर यहां पर
मेंशन कर दो तो स्टार्टिंग में तो
स्टार्टिंग में भैया देखो ये किसी भी केस
को चेक ही नहीं करेगा क्योंकि देखो यह
हमेशा ट्रू रहेगा यह हमेशा मैच करेगा तो
इन तीनों केस को मैच करेगा ही नहीं अगर
आपको यकीन नहीं होता मैं सिंपली क्या करता
हूं
इसको कमेंट कर देता हूं इसको मैंने सिंपली
कमेंट किया यह टेंटर कर दिया और मैं इसको
यहां पर कर देता हूं सिंपली देखो स्टार यह
आपको लाइव दिखाता हूं मैं एकको उसके
बाद
य
डिफॉल्ट डिफॉल्ट केस डिफॉल्ट केस कर दिया
यहां पर मैंने कंट्रोल ए कंट्रोल क्स देन
अब मैं इसको क्या करता हूं एग्जीक्यूट
देखो प्लीज एंटर नंबर 7890 र एरर लाइन
फाइव सिंटेक्स एरर नियर इंस्पेक्टर टोकन
ओके ओके ओके प्रॉब्लम इज दैट मैंने अभी तक
इसमें एक ये नहीं किया इसको क्लोज नहीं
किया ये रहा इसको मैंने क्लोज नहीं किया
कंट्रोल एस एक्स ये
रहा कंट्रोल
एक ये रहा कोई भी नंबर लिख दिया मैंने हिट
एंटर अभी दे डिफॉल्ट केस
कोई भी वैल्यू शो नहीं गया क्योंकि हमने
जो डिफॉल्ट पेज था केस था वो स्टार्टिंग
में लगा दिया ये हमेशा ट्रू रहेगा इसलिए
क्या है कि हमेशा डिफॉल्ट केस ही आएगा तो
यही कारण था कि आपको हमेशा एंड में यूज
करना डिफॉल्ट केस को एंड में क्या करना है
यूज करना है तो यह था आपका आज
का सेशन कंप्लीट आपका जो लॉजिक सेक्शन था
आज कंप्लीट हो गया मैंने लॉजिक सेक्शन में
आपको क्याक पढ़ाया कि चेंस ऑफ कमांड कैसे
बनाते हैं ज पर एंड
डबल पाइप मतलब र ऑपरेटर है एंड ऑपरेटर है
उसके बाद एंपर सड है देन मुझे एक और चीज
मैंने यूज किया था उसके बाद मैंने बताया
आपको टेस्ट कमांड कैसे यूज करते हैं जो आप
अभी तक यूज करते आ रहे हो लॉजिक लगाते आए
हो इफ कंडीशन के साथ और इफ इफ स्टेटमेंट
में आपको पढ़ा चुका हूं और उसके बाद केस
स्टेटमेंट आपको पढ़ा चुका हूं तो आपको
बेहतरीन तरीके से समझ में आ गया होगा कि
कौन सी चीज को कहां पर यूज करना है कौन सी
चीज को कहां पर यूज करना है कल मैं आपको
नहीं है के नेक्स्ट जो क्लास होगी उसमें
के स्टेटमेंट का क्या करूंगा आपको एक
एग्जांपल शो करके दिखाऊ कि स्टेटमेंट को
हम कैसे यूज करते हैं उसके बाद फर्द हम
नेक्स्ट सेक्शन पर जाएंगे ओके फदर हम
नेक्स्ट सेशन में जाएंगे सॉरी ब्रो आज का
टाइम हो गया मिस्टर 003 मैं आपको नहीं
सलूशन क्या करता हूं ना मैं
आपको ग्रुप में भेजता हूं आपको आपका
सोल्यूशन मैं नहीं आपको ग्रुप में भेजता
हूं वहां पर मैच कर लेना अगर जब समझ में
नहीं आए कोई डाउट आता ना तो मुझे मुझसे
पूछ लेना फिर ओके मुझसे पूछ सकते
हो ओके मुझसे पूछ सकते
तो आज का हम सेशन एंड करते हैं स्टिल यू
हैव एनी डाउट तो यू कैन आस्क मी
नाउ डोंट वरी हम क्या करेंगे ना अभी ऐसे
ऐसे प्रोजेक्ट करेंगे और आई एम प्लानिंग
दैट कि मैं कोई
एक अच्छी आप लोगों को नहीं है मैं आप में
से कुछ सोच रहा हूं कि कुछ लोग जो सिंसियर
लोग आते हैं ना हमेशा हर क्लास में फोर टू
फाइव उनका एक ग्रुप बनाऊंगा उनका कांटेक्ट
शेयर करूंगा और मिलकर एक अच्छा सा बेस का
टूल बनाएंगे लाइव प तुम्हे मजा आएगा और
ओके तो तुम्ह भी मजा आएगा और मुझे भी आएगा
उस टूल के और वो तुम्हारा क्या लाइव
प्रोजेक्ट होगा कितना भी टाइम ले लॉजिक
तुम लगाओगे मैं तुम्हारी सिर्फ हेल्प
करूंगा तुम्हें वन वीक 10 डेज जितना भी
लगेगा ओके तो प्लीज रिवाइज करते रज प्लीज
प्लीज प्लीज रिवाइज करते रहो ओके और उनके
साथ हम नॉर्मली तो मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा
सिखाऊंगा बट मुझे वो स्पेशल बंदे में धीरे
धीरे देख रहा हूं जो कंटिन्यू आ रहे है
उनको मैं चूज करूंगा उनका नाम जल्दी उनको
सरप्राइज मिलेगा सडन दे गेट ए ग्रुप
रिक्वेस्ट ग्रुप में आएंगे और एक बेस्ट का
अच्छा सा टूल बनाएंगे हम दिखाएंगे कि बेस
की पावरफुल हो के पावर आई विल ट्राई मा
बस्ट मैं सोच रहा हूं ऐसा कुछ करने का आप
लोगों के साथ जो बक बाउंट से रिलेटेड होगा
खास कर की स्टार्टिंग का फेज होता
है सब डोमेन एन्यूमरेशन ये सारी चीजें
करते वक्त ओके तो आते रहिए क्लास में तो
अच्छी बात है कोई डाउट नहीं है तो आज का
सेशन एंड करते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में जब
भी होगी कल या डे आफ्टर टमा जो भी होगा
मेरे का जो नेक्स्ट टाइम जैसे
मिलेगा और दिसंबर से पहले कंप्लीट कर
देंगे इसको बेस को डोंट
वरी
तो
तो नेक्स्ट क्लास में बात करते हैं
नेक्स्ट टॉपिक कुछ नहीं अभी आपके सेक्शन
बचे हैं सेक्शन में क्या ना कमांड्स
ज्यादा है आपके लॉजिस में जैसे कि आपका
फॉर लूप बचा है वाइल लूप बचा है और आपके
अरे बचे हैं आपको डी बग करना सिखाऊंगा मैं
और आपको सबसे इंटरेस्टिंग चीज बताऊ एक चीज
सिखाऊंगा शेड्यूल कैसे करते हैं ऑटोमेशन
ऑटोमेटिक शेड्यूलिंग कैसे करते हैं क्रोन
जॉब्स वाली चीज सबसे इंटरेस्टिंग आपके
स्क्रिप्ट के साथ वो सिखाऊंगा कि ऑटोमेटिक
कैसे क्रोन जॉब होगी आपके स्क्रिप्ट ओके
तो फिर चलो आज से करते हैं बाय बाय गुड डे
गुड
नाइट तो सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन बाय
बाय